yolande s'excuse aujourd'hui on avez
vous toujours rêvé d'être un dieu
quelqu'un de très puissant avec des
pouvoirs
êtes vous quelqu'un très chou du coup
aujourd'hui retombé sur ce maïs est un
jeu dans lequel on joue des [ __ ] de
dieu qui cassent des culs je me suis dit
que ça pourrait être cool de faire une
partie privée avec dix abonnés comme ça
en arène ces partis start the game allez
on y va
comme vous pouvez le voir j'ai mis tous
les level 30 avec moi parce que je suis
très mauvais joueur petacchi jouer
j'adore elle regardait avec son fouet la
doc elle c'est le dieu des chats ça
c'est le dieu des ailes et ça c'est le
dieu de la lumière c'est totalement faux
[ __ ] lui joue un pokémon à gauche quoi
ok c'est parti ça commence comme vous
pouvez le voir c'est un jeu dans lequel
on voit la troisième personne voilà un
peu comme dans les mmorpg
sauf que ce tome obama c'est la seule
info je donnerais sur ce jeu c'est parti
on va casser des cruches pour but un sas
faitelles tornade monga hausse voilà
j'arrive pas à coups de feu dans le vent
mais vous rigolez même pas assez
attention donnée deuxième info alors
pendant que ça se bat voilà jérôme
écartée il a voulu ma voix est a fait
quoi tu as cru j'étais petit je te mets
un coup de fouet non regardez c'est sûr
lucas bavarois alors elle fait du jeu en
fait ces deux buts et les millions et
demi pour pas qu'ils passent aux frères
notre portail qui est juste là voilà un
toto attend là je vais sauter je vais
tout était là là je vais fouetter mais
la puissance déjà vos questions à faire
et on a tué deux belles c'est grâce à
moi ça et je vais vous les sbires allez
allez allez je vous soutenir
un bijou avec les yeux pragmatisme
suivez moi quand j'attaque comme ça on
meurt tous
relis je n'aime pas le juger habré bla
et bla s'y attendait pas c'est le démon
c'est le démon évidence une toile ou
mais non mais le bol route perso à les
cours et lui tous après allez on va
l'avoir
oui oui c'est vrai qu'ils ont le vieux
chien je lui court après alors qu'ils
rampent par terre comme ça c'est quoi ce
bordel
oh non il est mort par un écureuil et un
écureuil qui a tué mon pote
jme fois le poète je vois tu je souhaite
je le vois je l'envoie sa peau il est
mort
mais non même envoyé un missile d'eau et
vas-y c'est pas juste c'est pas
timberlake tout ça c'est pas justin
s'est pas justin timberlake à l'est
d'alger plus beaucoup de vie quelqu'un
prenne à sainz alors ça ça veut dire
qu'ils retournent à la
bagel bagel bagel moa
mais la quetsche le foie de cocu je
souhaite le q ha ha ha pardon non mais
je rigolais aussi impopulaire et 1
victoire
voilà je ne connais pas ma tarte est
mort au revoir je m'en vais en faisant
des petits soleils arrière parce que
j'ai fait beaucoup de petits sont là là
on les a défoncé hui lui tout sur lui
tout sur lui
tout sur le poisson qui volent ne
laissez pas cette et à s'envoler à les
tuer l'homme
au fond je me bats moi j'ai envie d'y
aller aux [ __ ] à dégager une pulsion
aux mondiaux allez moi je suis lesbienne
sco - j'arrive à les tuer à la phrase
oui mais voilà regarder les va mourir à
jean bouin vague et je mets un coup de
fouet aux plats à l'essayage aille à
l'écureuil l'écureuil oh [ __ ] on a un
mec de 300 kilomètres à coups de pieds a
envoyé quelqu'un dans un trou je suis
sûr je vais défoncer l'écureuil regardez
ce [ __ ] des genres il est à nous je ne
vis que pour le tuer pour le dépecer il
va m'en vais m'abonner va mourir d'amour
et d'en tuer le voilà c'est bien on a
buté n'a cure haye
on va gagner le reste que 32 points
cette puce est typique ce stade en folie
les amis félicitations c'est l'heure de
tuer un écureuil reculé alors ils sont
les ennemis bon on les voit plus et
voilà je suis tombé et une équipe de
tueurs donc on peut voir vraiment que
j'ai fait la game voilà on le voit au
niveau des scores 1
on a un level 11 9 et 20 là en face ils
ont 30 26 30 39 passe piquée optique
avec moi cette fois je vais jouer qui je
peux jouer d'os on en asie beau de
diablo qui nous a rejoint et on a le roi
liche
avec cinquante kilos de moins qui est là
où je suis sur des nuages on la regarde
et vois même des avions passé dans les
nuages quoi se rend bien fait ok son
ulti cje mais voilà une zone de foudre
comme ça par exemple un ballon mais
voilà on n'a pas le temps on sent mal et
s'était créé du coup ils ont déchargé je
les fais péter blard ça fait mal au
monde il m'attire mais on lui a d'abord
noyalo maman battu c'était oui l'humour
dans cette vidéo il meurt et marie
marché a fêté la fois sur le buzz je
m'appelle 2g mais un bouclier allait à
yaya diallo
mais c'était un véritable finale auger
déjoue baisse tous un par un comme ça et
des mois et des mois les gars il avait
sa prison les gars je vais mourir
alan ont tué l'homme au coeur la tuer je
cours et je
et je cours et je m'en sors avec un
homme à la vie h et on a gagné un
contrat au jeu les piquets a aidé moi et
plus persona je m'en vais en mai à temps
il fait super mal à le vieux poulpe la
face même pas que c'est un robot on dira
murlocs poule olalalala longue jusqu'à
ce que vous avez dans qu aux plages leur
fait dégâts à distance
tu fais quoi toi mais tu t'es pris pour
que tu as dansé la capoeira dans mon dos
de dieu comme saab étaient faux oh mon
dieu non je savais c'était l'après
voulais juste me tuer moi ah ah les
[ __ ] victory levé vous peuple de la
reine
voilà on en déploiera duré quatre
secondes alors qu'après avoir joué deux
jeux alors est-ce que après avoir joué
deux jeunes sortent
il est dur à dire ce jeu de mots alors
est ce qu'après avoir joué 2 2 alors est
ce qu'après avoir joué 2 2 sens de
personnel
il est très mignon rock'n roll au keno
oui mais tu n'es pas crédible avec ton
petit corps alors on va tester l'ulti
junon à la non maman c'était génial
celui là il est un outil de darwin qui
sait trop bien
allez tiens tiens tiens tiens tiens
tiens tiens j'ai failli la tuer gps vous
avez vu ça au regard des repas
récurrente ou les jambes comme moi ce
que j'ai une que je suis allé en cure
aux hommes et les bêtes ils ont tout
misé sur moi d'un coup vous avez vu ça
les [ __ ]
voilà parfait ok je bac en plein milieu
j'en ai rien à faire je brade dans le
sol et je prends un gland non je vais
crever si je fais ça je me barre non aux
jo la bomba faune et des mois un regard
des jeux panique
spartacus ville des mots au moment où
ils abattent l'enfant eh bien vous savez
quoi je vous ai fait honneur parce que
rares sont les gens à voir bien mouvaux
aussi dégueulasse dans ce mic vient à
toi espèce de la petite kia qui a manqué
leur entame non non je n'aurais pas dû
je regrette d'avoir mais cette petite
qu'elle a avec bien là vient la bien au
chu
c'est un grand moment dans l'histoire de
smite lucas à faire un kill
effectivement de son vrai nom lucas
hochart il a réussi à tuer quelqu'un
aux mondiaux vous entendez vous savez ce
que ça veut dire qu'on vous dise tout
excité cette musique
cette odeur de transpiration au plein au
nom non le plein on a guetté victory web
et le monde j'étais mort et voit les
gens c'est déjà passé dix ans sur ce
match j'espère que vous a plu ces cas
n'hésitez pas aimer les vidéos que
d'habitude il faut que je joue plus
souvent avec vous puisque c'est vraiment
un truc marrant vous fait marrer en plus
nous permettait de gagner ce qui est
très rare enfin bref à savoir garder
porter ou bien qu'à toulouse bis
[Musique]